nicole is in chicago
welcome to the dave ramsey show nicole
hi how are you
better than i deserve how can i help yes
um i am 38 i live with my mom and i just
wanted to know i know you
hate the boomerang or adult kids living
at home
i do pay um half the rent half the
utilities
i just wanted to know should i keep
doing that until my school loans are
paid
or should i move out which would take me
probably double the time
what do you make i make 55
000 a year and my school loans are 63
right now
um but toward by the end of the year
it'd be
57 left and i'm
i just read your book the complete guide
to money
i've been doing everything wrong so i'm
trying to fix it i do have an emergency
fund
um i paid off all my credit cards i cut
them up
i'm only trying to pay cash um i did the
i'm doing the monthly budget
um and i just if i stay
continue to stay here i could pay off
the student loan in a year and a half
no longer than two um
but i am also helping my mom like i said
pay the utilities i haven't lived here
you know i did leave on my own once
with my ex it didn't work out so i came
back home i did the boomerang thing
um but i just want to know my plan
is to i never had a plan before and now
i do my plan is to
if i can stay here for i give myself a
three year plan
a year and a half to pay off my school
loans and then a year and a half to
save up for a home okay
or what do you what do you do for a
living
finance finance okay and what in what
regard what kind of finance
uh accounts payable okay cool good
good all right well and i have been
moving
up in in my field as well good
good good for you well what i love about
your whole story is
is that you now have a plan and that
you're executing a plan
um and so you got to have enough of the
story to know
you know how to look at your situation
so
um the way i answer questions on the
show is what would i do if i woke up in
your shoes or in
in your case my i've got my oldest
daughters just slightly younger than you
if if it was her i was talking to what
would i tell her
okay and so that's a combination in
other words of financial advice and dad
advice
does that make sense yes and then you
can decide whether you want to take any
of it or not because you're a grown
woman you get to decide these things
okay but um so my uh
concern is that i think you'll have a
high
overall and i think you would agree with
this five to ten years from today
we're used to five to ten years out
where you're still living there
that would indicate that emotionally you
had some work to do you need to get out
and be a grown person would you agree
with that
yes okay so that's not your goal and
that's not your plan
but that's the that's the overarching
concern in this is that
you get out there and go be who god made
you to be
and you square your shoulders and you
fight the rain and the sleet and the
snow
and you put your face in the sunshine
and you have this wonderful thing called
a life
and that's what i want you to do as your
friend okay
now can we delay that shortly in order
to hit some financial goals and make
when you step out a little bit better
yeah that's fine uh personally i'd
probably land
somewhere a little bit soon i'd probably
land
uh a little bit i'd make a couple of
modifications to your plan
uh modification number one is i would
pick up some extra jobs doing
bookkeeping
on the side and let's increase your
income ten or fifteen thousand dollars
and let's speed this up uh modification
number two is i would not stay there
until you got a down payment
i might stay there you got student loan
done so 18 months
18 months let's be done 12 to 18 months
let's be out of there
get you an apartment and then save up
for a house while you're in an apartment
and get get your life back going again
and you've got this other relationship
behind you
emotionally you're moving on to the next
chapter the the page turns in the book
of life for nicole
and you move on to the next thing and
mom's home was a blessing in the interim
you were blessing to her because you
picked up some of her costs
uh it was a safe place emotionally to
sit while you healed and
and knocked out uh some of these
financial things you discovered
planning for your finances while you
were there so that's a good thing that
happened while you were there
so i think all of that sounds great but
i'm probably going to say 12 to 18
months
you're debt-free because you're working
an extra job and you're out of there
does that make sense
yes and one quick question after that
sorry
sure no trouble [ __ ] so right after this
new moment is paid off
should i save up the three to six months
emergency fund prior to me moving out
or after i move i don't care you need
something okay
obviously you gotta have someone when
you move out but you don't have to be
all the way out
um and you don't even have to be all the
way out of the student loan for you move
i don't care
but you're just wanting to you're
wanting to use the financial traction
of no rent to speed this up
correct and i'm and i'm i'm giving just
giving you a nod and saying okay cool
but let's do it fast okay and so
anywhere in there i mean if you still
had five thousand dollars worth of
student loan debt
and you save up a couple grand to cover
some of your deposits and you go ahead
and move out because it works out better
to do that
because you're making killer money on
the side all of a sudden this this uh
bookkeeping thing you start on the side
i told you about took off or
you know you may want to go early i
don't care i'm not saying you got to
stay there you're just saying you'd like
to stay there
to speed this up and i'm going to stay
there the least
time that we can accomplish that goal in
air quotes
if i'm in your shoes because i think
what's going to happen is you're going
to have a different sense of dignity
when you get power over this money thing
that you've not had a different sense of
power in your life that you've not had
because you get power over money you get
power over a lot of stuff
and instead of it wagging you you get to
wag it
and that's a different thing and so i'm
i'm excited about where you are
very very well done it's honored to
speak with you thanks for calling in